secretary general uh will
preview tomorrow's extraordinary meeting
of nato defense ministers
and then we'll have time for your
questions secretary general
good afternoon nato defense ministers
will meet tomorrow
at the defining moment for our security
president putin's brutal invasion of
ukraine is causing death
and destruction every day
it has shocked the world
and shaking the international order
for months we have exposed russia's long
list of lies
they claimed they did not plan to invade
ukraine
but they did
they claimed they were withdrawing their
troops
but they sent in even more
they claim to be protecting civilians
but they are killing civilians
now
they are making absurd claims about
biological labs
and chemical weapons in ukraine
this is just another lie
and we are concerned
that moscow could stage
a false flag operation possibly
including chemical weapons
the ukrainian people
are fighting bravely
defending their roles
and their future
and we must support them
tomorrow we will be joined by the
ukrainian defense minister alexey
lesnikov
and our other partners georgia finland
sweden and the european union
the whole world has condemned this
senseless war world war
nato allies the european union and other
countries have introduced
unprecedented sanctions on russia
for many years nato allies have trained
tens of thousands of ukrainian troops
many of them are now fighting on the
front lines
allies have also provided significant
quantities of critical equipment
including anti-tank and air defense
weapons
drones ammunition and fuel
this training and equipment is helping
ukraine to defend itself
ukraine has a fundamental right to
self-defense enshrined in the u.n
charter and nato allies and partners
will continue to help ukraine uphold
that right
by providing military equipment
and financial and humanitarian
assistance
nato's core task is to protect and
defend all allies
we have responded to this crisis quickly
activating our defense plans
raising our redness and deploy the nato
response force for the first time for
collective defence
there are now
hundreds of thousands of forces on
heightened alerts across the alliance
one hundred thousand u.s troops in
europe
and around forty thousand troops under
direct nato command
mostly in the eastern part of the
alliance
backed by major air and naval power
as well as air defenses
the us is currently deploying hatred
batteries to poland
and germany and netherlands are also
deploying patriots to slovakia
all of this sends
an unmistakable message
an attack on one ally will be met with a
decisive response from the whole
alliance
russia's invasion of ukraine and its
military integration belarus creates a
new security reality on the european
continent
so we need to reset
nato's military posture for this new
reality
tomorrow ministers will start an
important discussion
on concrete measures
to reinforce our security for the longer
term in all domains
online
this could include substantially more
forces in the eastern part of the
alliance
at higher redness and with more
pre-positioned equipment
we will also consider major increases to
our air and naval deployments
strengthening our integrated air and
missile defense
reinforcing our cyber defenses
and holding more and larger exercises
i expect we will task nato's military
commanders to develop options
for our madrid summit in june
major reinforcements of defence will
require major increases in investment
i welcome that germany and other allies
have already announced they're stepping
up
and i encourage all allies to spend the
minimum two percent of gdp on defense
we must do more
so we must also invest more
to protect peace and freedom and uphold
our values at this critical time
and that i'm ready to take your
questions okay we'll start with cnn
thank you i'm wondering whether you can
say whether the nato alliance has seen
evidence that china has been providing
russia with any kind of assistance that
would help it on the battlefield whether
that's military equipment or mres food
for troops anything of that kind and
also with regard to the situation that
we saw earlier this week with russia
targeting a military base very close to
poland's border i'm wondering what you
can say about
the kind of red lines and whether there
would be
any kind of
consequences if
a missile for example worked
accidentally to enter nato territory or
on purpose thank you
so nato's core responsibility our main
responsibility is to protect and defend
all nato allies
1 billion people in 30 different
countries
and to
ensure that we also do that do that
now in a more dangerous security
situation in europe caused by the
invasion of ukraine by russia
we have increased the presence in the
eastern part of the alliance we have
increased the readiness of our troops
and we are deploying more capabilities
especially to the eastern part of the
lions
so an attack on one ally will trigger
the response from the whole alliance and
we are there to protect and defend every
inch of nato allied territory
when we see more military activities
when we see actually fighting going on
close to nato borders there is always a
risk for incidents and accidents and
therefore we have to make sure every
effort to prevent such incidents and
accidents and if they happen
to make sure that they don't spoil out
of control and create really dangerous
situations
we are very closely monitoring the
airspace
and and
the border areas
around nato
and our military commanders also have
the lines to their russian commanders to
help to prevent incidents and accidents
and also prevent them from spying
aspiring out of control if they happen
on china
so china should join the rest of the
world
condemning strongly the brutal invasion
of ukraine by russia
and
any support to russia
military support any other type of
support will actually help russia
conduct
a brutal war against
an independent sovereign nation ukraine
and help them to continue
to wage war which is causing
death
suffering and
an enormous amount of destruction
so
china has
an obligation as a member of the u.n
security council to actually support and
uphold international law and the russian
invasion
of
ukraine is a blatant violation of
international law so we call on russia
to
clearly condemn
the invasion and of course not support
russia and we are closely monitoring
any
[Music]
science of support from
china to
to russia
news agency of ukraine secretary general
and nato have a
glorious uh story
of supporting uh some countries and
preventing bloodshed for example like it
happened in uh ceravo in kosovo and so
on
uh
what is the threshold for nato uh when
the russian killings will
you know will overcome that threshold to
nato for direct involvement and uh the
short follow-up because of that if you
follow the russian rhetorics they are
not going to stop purely in ukraine so
that the question is
isn't the right time for nato to
intervene to defeat and to broke the
putin's military machine while it's
stick in ukraine while waiting when the
russian bombs will be falling to the
european capitals thank you
nato allies have supported ukraine for
many years and especially since
russia invaded ukraine for the first
time back in 2014
and the nato allies
like the united kingdom the united
states
canada have also helped to train tens of
thousands of ukrainian fortress
special operation forces and other jews
and they are now
bravely fighting
and assisting the invading russian
forces
and i think this support over many years
have proven extremely important
in
strengthening the ukrainian armed forces
and ukraine armed forces are much bigger
much stronger much better equipped much
better trained
now than in 2014
and i'm
glad that nato allah helped to achieve
that with the training and with the
equipment then of course it's first and
foremost the courage
of the ukrainian armed forces and the
ukrainian people and the ukrainian
political leadership that does us
actually enable them to fight back to
slow down to resist
the brutal invasion
conducted by the russian federation and
which is uh responsibility of president
uh putin
uh and it is president putin who is
responsible for this war he can end this
war now withdraw all his troops now and
then engage in good faith in a in a
political effort to find a diplomatic
solutions were calling on president
putin to do exactly
that
then nato's
ukraine is a
is a highly valued
partner
which we have supported and continue to
support and allies also stepping up
support partly with military equipment
partly with financial support
humanitarian support but also by
enforcing the sanctions which is uh
forcing uh uh which actually crippling a
russian uh economy
our our
our
responsibility as an alliance is to
protect
and defend all allies and we are
sending a clear message that we are
ready to do so by increasing the
presence in the eastern part alliance
but again it is russia and president
putin
that are responsible for invasion of
ukraine and president putin should end
this census war by withdrawing its
forces from ukraine
politico
thank you unbelief from politico
why do the u.s and nato insist that
fighter jets won't be helpful for
ukraine when the ukrainians themselves
say otherwise shouldn't it be up to the
ukrainian authorities to say what would
be helpful for them
thank you
nato allies are providing many different
types of equipment including advanced
air defense systems which have actually
helped
the ukrainians to shoot down
russian planes russian
missiles and the allies continue to
provide
support also when it comes to different
types of air defense systems but i will
not go into the details of every type of
supply every type of support
exactly how and where because i think
that will just make it harder and more
difficult to continue to provide this
type of support
we are nato allies are
stepping up and providing also advanced
air defense systems
thank you dan michaels wall street
journal to follow up on the earlier
question
there have apparently been uh uav
incursions into nato airspace
apparently one
russian drone entered and left polish
airspace and another one crashed in
nato territory
how do you determine when something like
that
is an act of aggression or an act that
warrants
response
um and you were talking earlier about
escalation um you know how how do you
ensure that something like that uh
is handled in a way that you know is
appropriate and doesn't get out of
control thank you
um
well i cannot confirm the latest
incidents you are referring to
but in general i can say that we are
stepping up
our vigilance our presence
the way we monitor
our airspace
and including by deploying
new patriot batteries to the eastern
part of the alliance and by doing that
and also
through our airwax surveillance planes
and increased the air policing air
patrolling
we are
both increasing
the capabilities we have to monitor to
track but also to
to
ensure that we are able to react if
if needed
and
[Music]
nato's integrated air missile defense
tracked the flight path of an object
which entered romanian airspace
on sunday uh
in response romanian fighter aircraft
scramble immediately
to investigate
and
and
the romanian authorities and nato are
reviewing this incident as we're also
reviewing the incident that ended with
the crash of drone in croatia um um uh
the indications we have so far on the
drone that crashed in croatia outside
the sagreb
is that that was not an armed attack not
an armed drone but it just highlights
that with more military activities
in the air
with drones with planes there is a risk
for instance accidents
and therefore we need to be extremely
vigilant we need to
react when needed and we need to
make sure that we
have the communications the line of
communications also with russians to
prevent
incidents from really creating dangerous
situations
so that's the reason why we
we are increasing the presence and also
the surveillance and monitoring of the
airspace overnight
bloomberg
maybe
bloomberg i just wanted to follow up on
what you said in your introduction about
um
the risk of a false flag event
and russia maybe using chemical weapons
how would nato respond in such a
scenario is this a red line for
potential
nato intervention thank you
any use of a of chemical weapons will be
a violation of international law will
be a violation of the ban that
or defeated that bans
chemical weapons and russia has assigned
to that
convention
and the
we call on russia not to use chemical
weapons uh callers are to withdraw all
its forces and to stop the fighting but
in particular
not to use any chemical weapons
um
russia has used chemical agents before
to attack and actually kill
political opponents
we've also seen that russia has
supported the assad regime in syria and
helped to facilitate the use of chemical
weapons several times in syria
and
any use of chemical weapons is is
is absolutely unacceptable and
and therefore it is also extremely
important that
russia understands that
it is
unacceptable if they
consider any use of chemical weapons and
we are also very vigilant
about the possibility of them trying to
stage some kind
pre-text
false drive operation to providing
excuse for any type of use of chemical
weapons okay we'll go to npr deutsche
baller leading pink
thank you very much um just somewhat of
a follow-up on natalia's question um
she was asking whether nato what nato
would do and whether this changes your
red line so as you say that you you are
looking at nato's military posture again
is this something that you would
consider changing you have said that
this would be a war crime and we know
that simply warning russia against doing
something is not enough of a deterrent
to stop it so if nato knows or if nato
sees that a chemical attack could take
place and you say that's a war crime
would nato consider changing the fact
that it would not intervene
in in such a in case of such a threat
thank you
our main uh
responsibility is to protect and defend
all nato allies uh it is important that
russia understands that we are there to
do exactly that
we have conveyed a very clear message to
russia about that we also
see when they try to
stage
pretexts for
you know for for the use of chemical
weapons we have seen that they
throughout this crisis have tried to
create different kinds of
uh false flag operations to try to
provide excuses for the use of force
uh we saw that in the leader to the in
intervention and now we have seen them
accusing ukraine and also nato allies uh
producing developing chemical weapons
and that's an absolute lie and therefore
it also makes us a bit concerned about
the possibility that they are actually
planning to do that
and um and the president united states
and other allies also made it very clear
that if they use chemical weapons there
will be a high price to pay
uh but i would not speculate about uh
any um any um
military response from the nato side
except for saying they say that nato's
main responsibility is to make sure that
we defend our protectoral violence
dpa
gentleman in white just behind yeah
just no okay
uh frankfurt algoland
after the demise of the
inf treaty it's been nato's position
that the russian deployment of ssc-8
will not be reciprocated
by the deployment of medium or
intermediate
nuclear-capable
missile systems
in the light of
the russian aggression against ukraine
and president putin's threats nuclear
threats to nato
in your view does this stance need to be
reviewed
the demise of the inf treaty was a
serious setback form for international
arms control because
the infj agreed in 1987 banned all
intermediate range record systems
and
then
over the last years or actually several
years we have seen that russia has
deployed a new missile
which
violates this treaty and then that led
to the demise of the treaty
a few years ago
um
[Music]
we have stated from the nato that and
and russia has deployed these uh these
weapons over now several years
um
the ssc-8
we have made it clear that we will not
mirror what russia does so we have no
plans to deploy
nuclear-capable intermediate-range
land-based systems in europe
at the same time we need to be able to
make sure that we are able to respond
and protect
all allies also in a new security
environment where russia has deployed
more new capacal missiles
and therefore we have to do many things
at the same time we need to strengthen
our air missile defense
we are doing that
we need to invest more in advanced
conventional capabilities
including fifth generation aircraft
and i welcome the german decision to
invest in fifth generation aircraft
we need
also to
increase the readiness
and our ability to monitor detect
and of course we also need to make sure
that
nato's nuclear deterrent remain safe and
secure and effective and that's exactly
what we're doing when we are now making
sure that we exercise and uh
and
ensure the effectiveness of our nuclear
deterrence
okay we have associated press
hi mark from associated press mr
secretary general what do you know about
the three european leaders visiting
ukraine today
nato allies and the european leaders
have had
extensive contacts with
with
ukraine and the political leadership in
ukraine
uh including with presidency over
throughout the whole crisis also to lead
up to the crisis i think it's important
that the
leaders of nato countries of european
member states are engaging closely with
uh president zielenski uh we will have
the defense minister of uh
of ukraine attending um
the the nato defense ministerial uh
tomorrow by video link
and uh and therefore i think it's
important that we at all levels in
different formats engage uh and meet
with uh the ukrainian political
leadership
well thank you interface ukraine during
the summer
this morning some mass media spread
information about possible extraordinary
summit nato summit
next week can you please confirm this
and second technical question
according to my information it stuck
for nato bureaucracy one and half week
to implement ukrainian request for fuel
can you please comment on this year
thank you
well nato allies are providing and have
provided a lot of different types of uh
support to ukraine some of this is
channeled through the
to the nato framework some are provided
bilaterally
and for us it is important that we
provide uh
uh support and shorten all this and that
we provide critical support which
ukraine needs so
uh overall i think the message is that
uh
over many years leading observation but
also after innovation uh allies have
been very quick in stepping up and
providing uh support
uh and again i'm a bit reluctant to go
into all the details about exactly how
and where and when but the overall
picture is uh that allies are providing
significant support
and they've done some short notice and
that's different types of weapons but
also that includes
fuel
then
while nato allies uh have us consulted
and coordinated closely
uh over several weeks uh both uh in the
lead up to the invasion but also after
the invasion we had a virtual summit
just one day after
and we'll have different ministerial
meetings also extraordinary ministerial
meetings and we will have an
extraordinary defense minister meeting
to tomorrow
then we will we are able to convene
also a nato summit with all the nato
leaders on short notice but i cannot go
into more details about that now
okay we'll take a couple of questions
online we'll go to utah released hours
in payoga
yes
thank you anna
secretary general uh i have a question
which many people in croatia are asking
how is it possible that the drone of six
tons heavy enters uh nato airspace and
flies for around an hour and crashed in
the capital of a nato member state while
you are so vigilant in defending the
nato sky
and do you know something more
whether it really was a drone without a
weapon or something because the prime
minister the minister of defense said
that there were there was a explosive
device in this flying object that
crashed in soccer thank you
well i spoke with the prime minister
penkovic on sunday and we are working
together to establish all the facts
about the
preliminary indications and information
we have is that this was an unarmed
drone
uh and that the drone was of course and
uh that it
it it ran off out of fuel and they
crashed outside the uh sarge warrior
crashed in
in croatia but but we will have more
confirmed facts soon but that's the
information we have so
far
i think also it is important to
to realize that
that uh
allies are exchanging information um
and that this uh
drone was
was attracted by the
uh the nato's integrated air missile
defense tracked the flight of
of the drone uh
that later crashed in sargrav but again
we will make sure that uh
the different allies that were involved
uh share all the information and then we
can establish all the facts about what
this happened i think if anything it
demonstrates the need to
further strengthen integration further
strengthen
information sharing among allies
and also
to invest more and upgrade
everything from radars to
to our presence of air and missile
defense systems and that's exactly what
we do
also by deploying more patriots in the
eastern part of the alliance
okay we'll go to
robert lupito
thank you very much for taking my
question uh mr secretary general i want
to ask you whether uh there will be a
speed up process uh for this
establishment at the nato
battle group in romania and also since
you mentioned about the reset in nato's
defense posture after russia's invasion
into into ukraine do you think that this
reset will also mean an unitary approach
both for the northern part of the
eastern flank and both for the southern
part of the eastern flank we will see
the same level of troops and defense
commitment in the baltics in poland and
also in romania and bulgaria thank you
very much
so we have already increased
significantly our presence in the
eastern part of the alliance also in the
black sea region
with more troops i went to
romania a couple weeks ago and i met
with the
u.s forces german forces and other
forces there
who have actually increased their
presence and now
the lead elements of the nato response
force have been deployed to romania
french troops
and this demonstrates that that
there is all the significant increased
military presence
in the eastern part alliance
we speak about 40 000
uh forces on high redness
and the direct nato command then we have
the national forces whereas the
bilateral arrangements
uh so in total this is a quite
significant presence uh
both in romania the
southeast of the alliance but also
also in the baltic region
this is our
immediate response
uh and and as i said the bat groups is
under establishment with the french-led
vjtf element
um then what we will discuss at the
defense ministerial meeting is not only
the immediate response and need for
support ukraine but we will also look at
the need to reset
our
presence our deterrence and defense
posture in light of the russian invasion
of ukraine and the integration of
russian and belercian forces
that will take some more time because i
think we need uh
to assess the different options we need
advice from our major commanders and i
expect that the ministers when they meet
tomorrow will agree a tasking will agree
to ask committee commanders to write
advice for more longer term adaptations
i think it's important to distinguish
clearly about the immediate response
all the tens of thousands of more troops
air
power and naval power
and then the more long-term uh
adjustment or posture they will take
some more time before you take fine
decisions i expect that to be made
at the nato summit at the end of june
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference we'll see you tomorrow
thank you